what do i have to do to get verified i
mean
how didn't you get identified you're not
verifying the instagram immediately
should be fair given that you have an
article coming out every week about you
and you're
you're guided yeah what the [ __ ] how did
you fail
how did what did you submit they were
like submit an article or a wikipedia
page
wikipedia because there were like 25
articles linkedin right
that's the mistake you guys made well
apparently so me and me and chris both
did wikipedia submission for
verification
yeah and god did the articles because i
didn't have a wikipedia dance the only
one who got it yeah
it's wild though you know not to like
anyone but i see people with like 10 000
followers
who have like one acting credit get
verified i mean because if you look at
the uh that's really bizarre yeah if you
look at the
specs that you need to get verified it's
like you literally have to have like a
page in imdb
instant verification or yeah i do yeah
or like any kind of
or like any kind of like a lot of
monetization about you but like a
wikipedia i think it's just like
anyone can write a wikipedia yeah yeah
trustee's podcast is an imdb listed show
yeah but didn't get twitter but didn't
get twitter verified yeah
i can't believe it so now now my goal is
to get trash chase verified before you
and you
yeah yeah exactly that's that's what we
got to submit right exactly
just submit that video we're good the
dream is we're all verified and chris
isn't yeah that that would truly become
a reality this month because
when i when chris hit 2 million
subscribers on youtube and i hadn't hit
2 million yet he never let me hear the
end of it
every time he did anything anytime
something happened to chris you'd be
like two million subs in it they just
want two million subs
why do you get the big bed oh it's two
million subscribers
he's joking imagine having two million
subscribers
oh wow look at this guy
how many years did it take
i'll get there i'll get there we'll all
get there soon enough
i'll make it only it will get there
eventually it's a matter of who first
right because we all know with how old
this [ __ ] goes
whoever gets verified first the other
person will not hear the end of it yeah
i do i i would rather end my youtube
career than have chris vera
chris you
i'm going to meet jack dawson like don't
get c-dog va verified yeah right the
only thing i have above chris right now
fact that i'm twitter verified if you
could have uh rang up jack dorsey to get
me not verified
why didn't you ring him up to get you
verified yeah he's a busy man don't want
to take it because jack's like one at a
time one at a time
which do you prefer are you verified or
chris oh conor not verified chris is the
kind of guy who would rather be like
conor not there yeah yeah
it's disappointing but yeah that's gonna
happen all right you'll get there you'll
get there eventually